Bonjour à tous, bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo.
Une vidéo un petit peu particulière
puisque c'est la 13ème sur la chaîne
et je me suis dit que le numéro 13 ça portait malheur,
donc j'allais vous faire un truc un petit peu différent
et donc cette vidéo va être un hors-série
où je vais faire un petit bilan
de ce qui s'est passé sur la chaîne
pendant les 6 derniers mois
et puis vous parler aussi un petit peu de l'avenir de la chaîne.
♪ [Générique] ♪
La chaîne existe depuis six mois maintenant
et je suis vraiment très content de ce qui s'est passé
puisqu'à l'heure où je tourne la vidéo,
il y a, à peu près, 7000 abonnés,
alors j'espère que d'ici à ce que la vidéo sorte,
il y en aura beaucoup plus.
Il faut savoir que chaque fois que
l'un de vous s'abonne, je reçois un petit mail
et donc ça fait 6 mois que je reçois plusieurs dizaines
de mails par jour pour me dire que les gens s'abonnent
et à chaque fois ça me fait l'effet
d'un espèce de petit câlin virtuel.
Merci à tous ceux qui se sont abonnés,
merci surtout à ceux qui ont partagé les vidéos
parce qu'on vous le dit souvent, mais c'est le principal
moyen qu'on a de faire connaitre notre travail
donc n'hésitez pas à partager des vidéos.
Je vais évidemment continuer à faire des vidéos,
je vais juste faire une petite pause pendant l'été
parce que déjà, j'imagine que vous avez peut-être
autre chose à faire que regarder mes vidéos
et puis moi aussi je vais avoir autre chose à faire
parce qu'en fait, je vais déménager.
Ça ne se voit pas forcément dans les vidéos,
mais j'habite à Boston aux Etats-Unis
et cet été je vais rentrer en France,
à Paris plus précisément,
donc, déjà, le décor va changer
et puis évidemment, pour moi, ça va être aussi peut-être
l'occasion de me rapprocher un petit peu plus
de la communauté des vidéastes culturels
et notamment des vidéastes scientifiques,
donc j'espère que c'est quelque chose qui pourra
aussi se voir dans l'évolution de la chaîne.
Parmi les nouveautés dont je voulais vous parler,
comme pas mal de youtubeurs,
j'ai décidé de créer une page sur tipeee.
Alors, pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas,
tipeee en fait, c'est un site
qui permet de faire du financement participatif
et ça fonctionne un peu selon le principe du mécénat,
si vous voulez, ou du micro-mécénat.
C'est-à-dire que vous avez la possibilité
de faire un don ou un micro-don,
pour soutenir des créateurs et notamment des vidéastes.
J'ai donc créé une page sur tipeee, je mettrai le lien
dans la description ou dans la vidéo, si j'y arrive
et ça permet à ceux d'entre vous qui le souhaitent,
de soutenir financièrement la chaîne en faisant un petit don.
Ça peut être un don complètement symbolique,
même 1€, vous savez, c'est déjà beaucoup.
Ma principale idée en faisant ça,
c'est avant tout d'essayer d'améliorer mon matos.
En fait, il faut savoir que, quand j'ai commencé cette chaîne,
j'ai démarré un peu avec ce que j'avais sous la main
et notamment, je filme avec un appareil photo,
que j'aime beaucoup pour faire des photos
mais qui n'est pas du tout adapté pour faire des vidéos.
Déjà, il ne peut filmer que pendant 10 minutes d'affilé,
ce qui est quand même un petit peu pénible
parce que vous pouvez vous douter que tourner
une vidéo, ça prend un petit peu plus que 10 minutes,
notamment, il n'y a qu'une seule focale fixe
que je ne peux pas changer
donc je n'ai absolument aucune possibilité
de faire des zooms, c'est ça ou rien.
J'ai aussi quelques petits problèmes de fréquence
d'image que certains ont vus dans les vidéos.
Voilà, ça j'aimerais vraiment l'améliorer.
Autre exemple, je tourne avec un micro
qui est sympa, qui n'est pas cher,
mais qui a une légère tendance à grésiller
quand on bouge les câbles
et donc je me retrouve régulièrement, au montage,
à essayer d'effacer les bruits de grésillement parasites.
Je perds pas mal de temps et d'énergie, en fait,
à cause du fait que je n'ai pas un matériel très adapté
et je préférerais dépenser ce temps et cette énergie
pour écrire de nouvelles vidéos,
ou alors améliorer mes illustrations, mes animations, etc...
Donc, si voulez aider la chaîne, me soutenir financièrement,
me permettre d'acheter du meilleur matériel
et donc de continuer à faire des vidéos
et à les faire régulièrement,
vous avez la possibilité de me soutenir sur ma page tipeee
dont je mettrai le lien quelque part
dans la description ou dans la vidéo, si j'y arrive.
Une autre chose dont je voulais vous parler, c'est que,
même si je n'ai pas un nombre démentiel d'abonnés,
je me suis dit que c'était un petit peu dommage
de ne pas en faire profiter les autres
et donc je vais essayer de vous parler
de quelques chaînes scientifiques que j'aime bien
et dont je pense qu'elles pourraient
avoir beaucoup plus d'abonnés.
La première, c'est cette chaîne qui s'appelle,
"Choux romanesco, vache qui rit et intégrales curvilignes",
oui, c'est son vrai nom.
En fait, il faut savoir qu'au départ,
"choux romanesco", c'est tout simplement
le meilleur blog francophone de vulgarisation
des mathématiques, en tout cas, c'est mon préféré
et ça fait maintenant quelques mois que l'auteur du blog,
El Jj, a décidé aussi de faire des vidéos.
Il a fait déjà, peut-être une petite dizaine de vidéos
et je vous recommande vraiment
d'aller les voir, elles sont vraiment bien
et notamment la dernière vidéo qu'il a faite
sur les fractales, elle est franchement renversante.
Allez-y et abonnez-vous à "Choux romanesco".
Une deuxième chaîne dont je voudrais faire la pub,
c'est une chaîne qui s’appelle "Motorsport Gigantoraptor".
Comme son nom l'indique en fait, la chaîne parle
essentiellement, d'un côté de voitures de course
et de l'autre côté de paléontologie, bon...
et l'animateur de la chaîne qui s’appelle Aurélien,
je crois qu'il a quelque chose comme 13 ans,
et il fait un boulot absolument incroyable.
Il explique notamment des tas de choses
sur la théorie de l'évolution
qui montrent qu'il a mieux compris la théorie
de l'évolution que la plupart d'entre nous
et vraiment, à chaque fois je suis bluffé par ce qu'il fait,
donc je vous invite à aller voir ses vidéos
et à vous abonner à sa chaîne.
Voilà, je voulais aussi répondre à deux questions
qu'on me pose très régulièrement dans les commentaires.
La première, c'est qu'on me demande
quelles études j'ai fait.
J'ai fait une thèse en physique théorique
et mon sujet était, je cite,
"Modèles de mousses de spin
pour la gravité quantique en 3 dimensions".
Alors, qu'est-ce que c'est, en gros,
j'ai travaillé dans un domaine
qui cherche à unifier la mécanique quantique
et la relativité générale
et qui s'appelle, la gravité quantique à boucles, dont
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire allusion dans certaines vidéos
et donc vous comprenez pourquoi je suis assez porté
sur les questions de relativité générale,
mécanique quantique, univers, tout ça...
et donc il faut vous attendre à ce que, à l'avenir,
je traite encore ces sujets là sur la chaîne.
L'autre question qu'on me pose souvent, enfin c'est
plutôt une remarque qu'on me fait en commentaire,
c'est pour me dire que je devrais contacter
Bruce, de la chaîne "E-penser",
pour lui parler de ma chaîne.
Alors en fait, rassurez-vous, Bruce connaît déjà ma chaîne.
En fait, il faut savoir que Bruce est un lecteur de mon blog.
Avant d'avoir une chaîne,
ça fait maintenant 5 ans que j'ai un blog
de vulgarisation scientifique
qui s'appelle aussi "Science étonnante"
et donc Bruce, de temps en temps, lit le blog
et on a déjà eu l’occasion de s'écrire,
on ne s'est jamais rencontré physiquement
mais on a déjà échangé sur des sujets
que je traitais ou qu'il traitait.
Dernier petit coup de pub pour finir, sachez que
je fais partie du portail qui s'appelle "VidéoSciences",
qui est hébergé par le "Café des Sciences".
"VidéoSciences", c'est en quelque
sorte un annuaire qui regroupe
quasiment toutes les chaînes Youtube
de vulgarisation scientifique,
donc si vous ne connaissez pas "VidéoSciences",
je vous invite à aller voir
et je suis sûr que vous allez découvrir plein de chaînes
scientifiques que vous ne connaissiez pas forcement
et dont j'espère qu'elles vous plairont.
Voilà, c'est tout pour ce premier hors-série.
Je sortirai probablement une dernière vidéo
d'ici 2 semaines, avant l'été
et puis après, on se retrouvera
en septembre dans un nouveau décor,
avec des nouvelles vidéos.
Et d'ici là, je vous dis, à bientôt !